welcome to deep mind the podcast where
we're exploring the world of artificial
intelligence we're assessing what we
know and what we don't know we're
looking at what we're trying to know
we're calculating what we will know
mapping out where we're going and
working out how we will know when we get
there I'm Hanna Frey and I'm an
associate professor in mathematics and I
spent the last 12 months at deepmind
and in this episode we are going to
start looking forwards to the future the
self schooled variety of AI known as
artificial general intelligence but
first you know what I don't feel like we
really given you the Grand Tour of this
place deep mind headquarters in Kings
Cross in London so follow me in my
squeakiest of sneakers closed doors
coming through so the language they do
machine learning understanding language
with me is the extremely likeable Coria
Caracciolo one of the right firsts
deepmind is joining way back in 2012 is
actually it's a group of people who are
either focused on agents better memory
more planning how can we get him get
those into the agents all of your rooms
are named after famous mathematicians
Gauss room Hedy Lamarr Oh actually I
know her I know her she's actually a
very famous actress you know I liked her
best in I take this woman with Spencer
Tracy but she was actually also
scientists right the deep learning group
is more interested in just like coming
up with algorithms and architectures on
any data domain some seriously delicious
equations on the whiteboard I've learned
yes
I mean blackboards and whiteboards if
you have an idea in the corridor it's
important use it this area is the
machine learning so one of the main
projects going on here with this group
is the imitation just just demo so
Sabres in the office this is the area
for the neuroscience group they do a lot
of thinking about what are the important
problems what are the challenges that
the discipline is really hard yeah table
football seven of my course a regress ah
the reinforcement learning team this is
one area that has been core to what we
try to achieve with a GI if you're
interested in agents it has to be active
they've got some proper weight eat
expose that's not not exactly bedtime
raging is a molecular electronic
structure theory I know what all of
those words mean but just not in that
particular order sweeping funds sleeping
I didn't know that they've been coming
in for a year no one told me about these
there anyone in there
look in my defense she didn't have a Do
Not Disturb sign on the door okay enough
of that already back to the simple stuff
like solving the Enigma of intelligence
just one tiny snag before we get there
first we're gonna need a proper
definition of what intelligence is
because intelligence you see it's quite
a slippery beast to pin down
[Music]
we've got a bit of a head start when it
comes to human intelligence although it
might not be everyone's favorite metric
IQ is one of the most stable
psychological tests we have and it does
a pretty good job of measuring limited
intelligence markers like reasoning and
logic but IQ still doesn't get us any
closer to a definition of intelligence
if we're going to get anywhere with this
we need to define it properly we need
some way to capture what we mean by
intelligence that works just as well for
humans and dogs as rabbits and machines
and there have been a few suggestions
for what intelligence is over the years
in 1921 the psychologist V Henman said
intelligence was the capacity for
knowledge and knowledge possessed which
sounds quite good on the surface until
you realize that it also applies to
libraries libraries can possess
knowledge do libraries count as
intelligent probably not in 1985 Marvin
Minsky the cognitive scientist said that
he thought intelligence was the ability
to solve hard problems and that seems a
bit more like it it also captures what a
eye has already proved it can do
here's Riya Hansel senior research
scientist at deep mind in the last few
years there's a huge number of different
narrow specific things that programs can
do as well as a human they can interpret
your voice as well as a human they can
maybe translate from English to French
and back again almost as well as a human
they can recognize things and images
almost as well as a human these sort of
narrow specific things
that word narrow is not to downplay the
transformative power of this sort of
thing just in this series we've looked
at energy conservation medical diagnosis
and protein folding all of which
certainly show the machines ability to
solve hard problems and all of which are
examples of narrow AI but real
intelligence general intelligence that
needs something else something more some
scientists have described intelligence
as the capacity to learn or to profit by
experience others think it's about
adapting and thriving in the environment
you find yourself in but whoever you are
smart disagree that's somewhere along
the line intelligence is something about
your ability to interact with an
external environment and being able to
adapt has to be part of it too so you
can't be fully familiar with the
environment you've got to be able to
deal with unanticipated challenges that
get thrown at you if you're intelligent
in 2007 after going through hundreds of
competing arguments Shayne leg one of
the three co-founders of deep mind wrote
an influential paper in which he and his
co-author tried to pin down precisely
what was meant by intelligence and here
is the definition that they came up with
intelligence measures an agent's ability
to achieve goals in a wide range of
environments and that is what they are
aiming for in this building here's a
reminder of what a senior research
scientist Maurice Shanahan told us in
Episode four the holy grail of AI
research is to build artificial general
intelligence so to build AI that is as
good at doing an enormous variety of
tasks as we humans are so we are not
specialists in that kind of way you know
a young adult human can learn to do a
huge number of things and can indeed do
an enormous number of things and can
adapt to a huge number of different
challenges you can learn to make food
you can learn to make a company you can
learn to build things to fix things you
can do so many things
to have conversations to rear children
so although those things and we really
want to be able to build AI that has the
same level of generality as that and
that's really still an open challenge we
don't really know quite how to get there
but if anyone has an idea of what it
will take its dem assess our best the
CEO and co-founder of deepmind
will be talking to him in the next
episode of our Adi but for now here is a
little glimpse into his thinking I'm
waiting to see a lot of key moments for
example I think a really big moment will
be when an AI system comes up with a new
scientific discovery that's of Nobel
prize-winning level that to me would be
a big watershed moment so you know
capable some kind of true creativity in
some sense I think other big points will
be when it can use language and converse
with us in a naturalistic way it's
capable of learning abstract concepts
these are all things that I think a
high-level cognitive abilities that
we're nowhere near yet and I think will
be big so I'm posting on the way
now it's reasonable to be asking
yourself how do you even approach such a
colossal task where do you even start do
you totally and completely believe that
AGI as possible yes back to my tour
guide core I cover to Luke he's the
director of research at deep mind I
believe that they will come where we
will be at that stage right now we are
not right now all we can do is go back
from that and then have a hypotheses
about the important problems the
important algorithms that we need to do
the important solutions like those key
things we need to have and then start
building more and more and more so let's
take an example then let's say the first
day that someone at deepmind decided
they wanted to look at the problem of
navigation so building an agent that you
can drop into an environment yes
where it's going do you just have like a
big brainstorm on a whiteboard of all of
the different possible aspects that
might contribute to being able to build
that agent yeah it starts with that
because if someone must work on
something like that then probably there
will be a good number of people here who
would be interested in the same thing we
will start discussing okay what is the
goal like when we say navigation you
gave a particularly good example right
like going from here to a given location
how are we going to specify it what kind
of environment this is what kind of
control space does the agent have all
these start affecting what kind of
algorithms we should use and are we
going to do this purely from vision are
we going to do this in a simple
environment in a grid world or we're
going to start from a grid world and
then we need to think about the path
towards going to a 3d environment are we
thinking about actually also putting
this on a robot like with real vision
like all that discussion starts
happening there's massive then I mean
just that one form is enormous it is but
that's why it's also research a big part
of it is trying to constrain the problem
space like being able to write down and
specify what what you want to do and
then making sure that it is actually a
challenging problem and there are good
metrics that we can quantify or we're
saying you're successful right exactly
and that itself as I said is quite an
iterative process and getting that
critique getting that view from other
researchers starts at that point in time
because like when the research is at the
idea space at the initial stages it's
actually quite important to formulate
the right problems and and sort of the
right context Adi is not going to happen
overnight it's the reason why as you
heard on the tour there are so many
different research groups in this
building you're not going to crack Adi
by attacking on only one front a
formulating the right problems means
going beyond individual skills like
navigation and drilling down into the
building blocks of intelligence and
- from the beginning of deepmind if the
goal is about a GI then it has to invoke
control it has to involve an active
algorithm and that is why you need to do
reinforcement learning that is why you
need to work on agents we need agents
that can interact with their environment
that can learn through trial and error
what actions to take
what karai calls its policy it's a
fundamental thing that you would expect
to find in any intelligent being humans
dogs or agents and so if the scientists
can get it right in one application the
lessons learned should apply elsewhere
the gist of training an agent is you can
start completely from scratch and then
slowly the agent builds that knowledge
that strategy of how to achieve a
certain task and it creates it builds it
comes up with its own strategies it
comes up with its own policy so then of
course looking at it and trying to
understand does that pose make sense
does that buy is it doing that policy
sometimes it's so surprising because
it's something that we haven't thought
about before sometimes you look at it
and you see that need that doesn't make
sense yes it it achieves something but
it's clearly not optimal can you
remember when you first realized or
believed that AGI was possible so we
tried these agents on Atari games and
they didn't do much and we couldn't we
couldn't make them work right like there
was a there was a team of like like like
several people there and we couldn't
make them work and then slowly we
started simplifying the problem and
simplifying the problems and find the
problem and we ended up with a very tiny
simple trivial problem like really just
like a five pixel by 10 pixel image and
one pixel moving in that image and the
agent trying to control that and once we
reduced the problem to that which I call
the emne stuff reinforcement learning
really
we could find the working solution we
started having this deep reinforcement
learning agents working right because
it's a simple problem of course you can
write a program to solve that but the
idea was like try to do deep
reinforcement learning and try to solve
it that way try to solve it from pixels
try to come up with a system that we
think can generalize to more to two
different problems more problems and
once we saw that actually it was a
matter of weeks we had ten or fifteen
Atari games like being sold like from
that tiny thing in the matter of weeks
you go to Atari that that was a big
moment that's what we keep in going that
like we select more and more diverse set
of problems that we think are important
at the end for AGI that is a key point
here intelligence is an agents ability
to achieve goals in a wide range of
environments so to get to AGI we need
agents to solve harder and more diverse
problems
you're listening to deepmind the podcast
a window on AI research the closer we
get to AGI the more powerful and
sophisticated this technology gets and
the more we rely on it in our everyday
lives the more dramatic the consequences
could be of us misunderstanding the
limitations of the algorithms and that
is why in parallel to pushing the
science forward researchers are also
working to ensure right now the agents
are reliable adaptable and crucially not
corruptible
[Music]
you show the image of a bus to a neural
network and it will say this is a bus
right there's a bus in this image well
it turns out that you can take the same
image modify it a little bit which is
almost invisible to a human eye but the
neural network will say that it's
actually an ostrich this adversarial
attacks are things some most of the time
that are invisible to the human eye that
doesn't change the actual content of the
image too much we don't perceive it but
because these are algorithms and bastes
they're they are sensitive to even very
small fluctuations in the input data
then it changes it changes the output
why does that matter why do you want to
stop that from happening in the real
world ai well for two reasons one of
them as I said is robustness because
when we trained these algorithms we want
them to be useful in real world and we
train them on datasets that we captured
from real world
but like you cannot know exactly what's
going to happen
of course what kind of data is going to
be at the end of today this algorithm is
going to consume so we want to make sure
that the algorithms are robust to these
kinds of potential like noise like
things that you want your algorithm to
be robust to that right and from another
point of view it's about safety being
able to say that like someone maybe with
an adversarial intent won't be able to
change the output of this algorithm
output of this neural network just by
making very small adjustments to the
inputs we have a we have a whole
research group actually on that on
working on rigorous and more robust
artificial intelligence because yes
these are real things in the end we are
training these algorithms and as I said
it's not just like looking at them but
we're trying to do more quantifiable
research on understanding why they are
doing what they are doing and trying to
interpret that and part of it is also
understanding how robust they are
[Music]
we have already seen real examples of
just how fragile intelligence can be
researchers have shown that you can add
a little bit of black tape to a stop
sign that will trick a driverless car
into speeding up the tape is so subtle
that it would look innocuous to a human
driver but it's just enough to make the
algorithms inside the car miss read it
as a 45 mile an hour speed limit sign
instead of an instruction to stop other
scientists have worked out how to fool
facial recognition algorithms into
thinking someone is mere Yakov it just
by making them wear a specially designed
pair of tortoiseshell glasses and the
images that are used for medical
diagnosis can end up giving wildly
inaccurate results just if a slightly
different brand of scanner was used to
take them you want to reach a state
where you can actually guarantee that
things like that won't happen that's the
main idea behind doing this research so
not sort of try to defend against
particular adversarial attacks or
examples but actually come up with
systems that are going to be robust no
matter what from the other point of view
of course if you are thinking about
agents there's the whole safety issue
what do you mean when you guys talk
about safety what are you actually
talking about if we have an intelligent
algorithm making decisions for itself
you want to have some sort of guarantees
that I mean it's acting with its own
policy it is aligned with what you
intended it to do if you think that
these algorithms continued learning all
the time
then we want that process to be also
producing an agent that is aligned with
what we have intended for it to do fill
in the gaps for me never give an example
of what you're trying to avoid it
becomes quite technical in the sense
that it's not like you are trying to
avoid the agent from making a mistake
right because mistakes happen right like
betraying policies and they are not
always optimal data
to the writing all the time it's not
about that really it's more about you
have a learning algorithm and you want
to make sure that it sort of conforms to
certain boundaries of behavior in
essence if we can develop safe robust
ethical AGI then the impact could be
staggering
but as demmas mentioned so too could the
discoveries on the way to Adi has agent
learned to solve increasingly hard
problems Trevor back is a product
manager for the deep mind science
program he played a key role in the
Moorfields Eye Hospital collaboration
that we talked about in episode 5 but he
also has a hand in deciding what the
future holds for deep mind and what
challenges and opportunities lay in
store for them to tackle next so we're
really at the stage of exploring what
other areas we should work on but the
possibilities are endless if you look at
the way the alpha fold system works
there's nothing really specific in there
to protein folding it's around
understanding the way that atoms
interact the way that you can build
material from base concepts so looking
at material design is a really exciting
stage you know could you design or
imagine a high-temperature
superconductor that's been sort of
brought to life through an AI algorithm
right is there more efficient ways of
looking for those types of materials why
do we care about high-temperature
superconductors so this is the amazing
opportunity of working in in science so
our previous work in healthcare has been
focused on very specific problems and it
takes a lot of time and effort and
energy to build an AI system that works
for those specific problems if instead
you can spend your time and energy
solving a fundamental science question
then perhaps you can you know instigate
a whole new field of interest and
potentially impact a much wider array of
problems so why is superconductivity a
problem you know if you could solve
superconductivity not only could you you
know solve a lot of the energy problems
by having a larger
genetic field around fusion but you
could also create a new type of
computing system you know there's lots
of opportunities that come from just a
single breakthrough in one of these
areas I think it's important not to
understate this because the idea that
you could have some kind of an impact on
nuclear fusion
for example the implications for the
earth and humanity are just enormous
right exactly I think this is the reason
I came to D mind was the opportunity to
have the greatest impact I could in the
world and I think AI is one of those
revolutionary technologies that
amazingly could you know impact
everything we do but also everything we
think about doing in the future and the
sort of opportunity to explore and
search the space of opportunities is
really something that's well designed
for AI to do it's a very efficient
search algorithm and so if you're able
to set up the problem in such a way that
is searchable via a are you really could
have 10 a hundredfold type of increase
in the opportunity for finding novel
materials or finding anomalies in
astronomical data you know finding new
types of stars finding more black holes
you know all these types of
opportunities are available simply via
the application of AI and it's not
stupid to say that actually lots of the
biggest problems that face humanity at
the moment are science problems right
like you know access to food and water
climate change healthcare all of these
things is stuff that AI can make
progress in I think that's right I think
a lot of the the sort of physical
problems that exist in the real world
are certainly things that if you can
make a difference to some of the the
sort of foundational science aspects you
know you could reduce the cost of energy
essentially down to zero or you could
make food more readily available across
the world and so that would really help
society progress in a number of ways
it's a tantalizing prospect solving
intelligence and creating a G I will
take the full range of research explored
in this podcast and more memory
reasoning logic learning language
embodied cognition and more so much more
and we're going to explore some of those
ideas in our next episode when I meet
with deepmind co-founder demis hassabis
he tells us how he created the world's
leading AI research outfit reveals what
keeps him up at night and opens up about
his hopes for the future I'm just
fascinated and also troubled by the
things around us that we seemingly don't
understand all the big questions you
know the meaning of life had the
universe start what is consciousness all
these questions which I feel like a
blaring sort of klaxon in my mind that I
would like to understand and my attempt
at doing that is to build AI first if
you would like to find out more about
artificial general intelligence or
explore the world of AI research beyond
deep mind you'll find plenty of useful
links in the show notes for each episode
and if there are stories or a sources
that you think other listeners would
find helpful then let us know you can
message us on Twitter or email the team
at pod cast that deep mind calm you can
also use that address to send us your
questions or feedback from the series
you